ronnie what do we got some kind of fire
we got units headed out there now
[Applause]
this movie is terrifying how did you
approach
creating these scares when we'd already
had the surprise of seeing the monsters
we knew the conceit what was your
approach to the sequel to keep that
tension
it's really uh interesting because i
think that
if i'm honest i was as scared as
everybody else about doing a sequel
because
i'm a fan first and a director and actor
or whatever second so
i was thinking sequels are usually a
cash grab a big blockbuster breakthrough
for
you know the studio play and i didn't
want to be a part of that and i loved
the first movie and i didn't think i
could make anything as personal
and then i realized in the story well
what if i just took the organic approach
which is
what happens after father promises that
if you stay with me
everything's safe and i'll protect you
forever once that promise is inevitably
broken a little more intensely in our
movie but um
what happens to the kids and i realize
the kids are the continuation of that
metaphor
and that's what growing up is and so i
took the exact same approach with the
scares which is
instead of my anxiety telling me to
try to make it so scary and so big and
just think about that the whole time
i thought actually i'm not going to
think about the scares at all and i'm
going to tell the story
and if i'm lucky because you care about
these characters so much you'll be
as scared if not more scared than the
first one you mentioned the kids and it
really feels like
millicent's movie as well as but she's
she's kind of the ripley of this story
she's nice
and what was that why did you why did
you just make it decisions that's huge
um well there was two things one was so
the little idea i've mentioned before
that i had this tiny idea that
when they asked me to do the second one
i said no but i had this tiny idea the
tiny idea was to make
millie the lead of the second movie and
it wasn't millie the actress it was the
story of her character and how
well i knew that she would pull off this
magic trick which is
if my character was sort of a anchor of
sorts to the first movie
um i always saw my character as a big
supporting character in the way that
all the other characters uh story
storylines
are either created or anchored by me
that she would have to be the same in
this and that there was something
so heroic about this little girl not
only continuing all the things that i
had taught her from the hearing aid to
the
speaker and all those things but
actually in a much bigger way this idea
of hope
and i think one of my favorite lines in
the movie is when she said because dad
would i have to go try to save these
people because dad would
and i think that that idea to me is a
much bigger idea and i think that is the
idea that we all have to believe that
the youth in the world
has to always remain the the group that
is most hopeful
and that no matter how dark things get
in this world
the fact that this little girl would say
yeah but i'm still going to be brave
enough and courageous enough to light a
candle in this darkness
i mean that stuff makes me tear up just
talking about it let alone seeing it in
a movie
and she pulls it off as a performer i
mean she's one of the best actresses i
think
i know i've ever worked with i know
emily's ever worked with and
there is something so unbelievably
otherworldly about her in a way
and i mean that in the best sense it's
it's it's not only effortless how good
her performance is but she is so
connected
in a way that you would expect an actor
who's 94 years old who's experienced
life in every single facet
she's able to uh sort of gravitate and
pick up on all these tiny nuances that
she really shouldn't be able to at that
age
she's she's a she's an incredibly
talented girl and finally you're looking
forward to exploring potentially more
parts of this world mm-hmm oh am i yeah
oh sorry
that was right um you know it's
it's funny the first movie i truly never
thought there would be a sequel i don't
think anybody thought there would be a
sequel i don't think the studio thought
there would be sequel and of course
i didn't want to do a second one because
of the success of the first one
as corny as it sounds i wanted to do a
second one if i could pull off
the level of trust and respect the
audience gave me
if i could find a way to return that
level of respect and trust
then i'll do it and so for me
i was never thinking about a first one
but i had all these questions when i was
doing or a second one when i was doing
the first one
like the fires when i light the fire on
the first one and there's fires off in
the distance
i personally was so obsessed thinking
what would it be like to explore
those other people and so this time in
the second one any time i had those
thoughts
i started writing them down in case for
a rainy day there was ever a third one
i don't know why you came all the way up
here there's nothing left
please the eveline that we meet here is
the evelyn we saw
the last seconds of a quiet place yeah
and she's kind of badass she's ready to
kick some ass
what's it like to play a full-blown
sci-fi heroine in this one
and were there inspirations of others
from the past that you do from
i wouldn't say i necessarily drew on
other sci-fi heroines
um i think for me being able to kind of
continue this character
and broaden the horizons for this
character based on her new set of
circumstances
which are inevitably just more intense
more heightened
more dramatic was really exciting
because i understand this character so
well
she's incredibly personal to me um
partly because of who she defines how
she defines herself and she's got that
sort of biblical maternal sense you know
that is just so
beautiful to get to play and certainly
something i can draw
a lot from my own experiences with my
kids and
um and i just thought you know the
stakes are so high for her this time she
has a brand new baby
um husband's gone house is burnt down
nowhere to go
who does she go to who's gonna help
three children she's trying to keep
alive
so i think if the stakes are that high
it is that big question like how far
would you go to protect your children it
turns out should go pretty far
pretty far indeed yeah do you have any
tips for keeping your baby quiet during
the apocalypse
maybe not putting them in a box um i had
this trick with my kids
that uh they both quite liked a little
pacifier when they were babies
and um i had this trick that the pasty
would be in the mouth and if they're
crying you just tap on the passy
really gently tap on it evelyn should
have picked that up she didn't have a
pacifier i guess
yeah hard to get supply but speaking of
the kids
this is kind of the kids movie wilson
and noah are
fierce and incredible i thought melissa
was like a new ripley isn't she
incredible
how have they grown in the intervening
years between when you show oh my god
plays one or two to be honest like
working with them is
is a really arresting experience because
i don't consider them
child actors you know they are just inc
wonderful partners in a scene
so prepared so nuanced so detailed so
knowledgeable about
what they want to bring to a scene how
they want to stretch it around how they
want to push you
that i don't consider them as like
actors who needed to grow
or learn they just are brilliant and
you know for us when it came to
millicent certainly when john's writing
it
it was very evident that this needed to
become her film in many ways and
she is so powerful has such gravitas and
presence to her
you believe this kid can do it you need
to believe this
child can do it and i think millie just
has
all of that power and all of that
presence and if the idea of it is that
the children
are our future in some ways you know
then it really ultimately had to become
their film
bathtub furnace what's next what's he
going to do
like claustrophobic hideous experience
um
i don't know i don't know tell him to
take it easy on you next i know he used
to take it easy i was like can we shoot
something in like
hawaii next time you know something like
that preferably with shoes
[Music]
what did you think when you went and
spoke to john about the film and saw
that you were going to have
this really significant lead role
well when john brought up this idea
about the second one he said he wanted
to talk with me about it
and i definitely wanted to hear him out
it was amazing how
how different it was uh
it is a different story i mean and it
works it works
uh it as a as a movie and the story
works and i was so excited to do it
and your character has this really
beautiful bond um with killian's
character specifically and i'm wondering
what was it like to work with with
killian
oh it was fun uh we had
we had our moments together that were
really nice and
we read a lot of books we focused on
that on talking about what we're reading
yeah what books were you reading
at the moment i was reading things for
school
actually textbooks but we shared our
thoughts
about what i was reading and things like
that this was a more physical
role for you this time a lot more stunts
a lot of running
how was the challenge of doing that it
was
it was huge um i needed to make sure
that i was healthy that i drank enough
water that i was eating right that i
slept well
and actually was good for me and uh i'm
young so it's a perfect time to do a
film like this
absolutely um you worked with john on
the first film obviously as a director
how had he changed as a director or
grown as a director
for a quiet place popular no i don't see
a change
not really um he's still
ha i mean he's so creative and uh
he he's still open to new ideas he says
why don't we try this and try that
and involves us in conversation and and
he has
really great communication and a
wonderful relationship with the cast so
i would say all of those things have not
changed
was it kind of like coming back to a
family yes it was
yeah now we saw a lot of interesting
developments in this film
new characters new worlds and i'm
wondering is it something you'd like to
explore in
a quiet place three
oh what a question i have no idea if
there will be um and i have no idea what
will happen
i find it a very interesting world
though
when you're fighting these monsters can
you describe to me
what's actually happening on set are you
looking at a tennis ball are you
fighting a person in a green suit
well there are a lot of different
elements the way we film it
um some are filmed with a man
some it's just some of it are just taped
off areas of where the eye gaze
is where the monster is or where
actually and also with sound
um so someone will give audio cues
so not scary at all well we try to feel
scary
uh but the set was scary enough actually
and when you're acting with other with
your cast
you do you build it you build that world
you can feel it
so it helps when you're with you know
your your cast members who are bringing
it to life
congratulations on the film guys very
scary but also very moving
and i think part of that has to do with
you killian in your relationship with
millicent's
character in this movie it's really a
beautiful growing bond that we get to
witness and i'm wondering
is that something that drew you to the
project oh
yeah 100 i mean i i um
i found the first film very very
emotional
i i went to see with my two boys
and uh i i it really took me by surprise
obviously it delivers in all the jump
scares and all of that stuff but in
terms of how emotionally
affected i was i was really surprised by
that and moved by it
and uh so then that the second move the
second movie the script of the second
movie
had that in it very much and i thought
that the relationship
between my character and millie's
character was really
interesting because they start at one
place and end up with another
and what was it like for both of you
working with her as an actress because
she gives this kind of
mind-blowingly good performance for her
everything is extremely emotional and
very
you know her approaching conveying
emotions was so
it's so greedy and so you know
raw and so organic
yeah i learned i learned to create it's
it's amazing to watch
to watch her just be yeah she's got an
aura
man like in real life yeah and then on
screen and you just
can't learn that it's just you know i
mean
you can't teach that she's kind of she's
special yeah um
be remiss for us not to know that you've
been in a film not dissimilar to this 28
days later
oh yeah a few years ago make like a long
day
a little while ago more than 28 days but
for both of you
do you think you'd do better fighting
off zombies or surviving
this alien monster invasion the essence
of the the theme really running through
the story is not so much the creatures
is
so much more of the scarce you know
the idea of being an environment in
which you're limited to
making sound where you you know the
uh the importance of existing
is really making sound making noises
you know and so that is taken away it's
almost like your oxygen is taken away
from the minute you're born you know and
do you think you'd fare better against
zombies or or alien monsters
well you know you have to separate me
well like i said earlier actors would be
terrible survivalists
because you know we would have known to
bring us snacks
and tea and you know
it it's it's i i can't find myself i
can't
locate myself in a in an apocalypse what
i would say though is
the thing about protecting your children
right that
instinct which is so primal
as a parent you you know you trust
that that would kick in above all and
that
you would be able to you would hope that
you would be able to do that you know
the people that are left another kind of
people weren't saving